thank my family one day only on America  today out here is where America's Heroes  play and you can too hi I'm JT Boyd  retired marine leadership performance  coach and reenactment enthusiast now you  can take America's tax dollars out for a  test drive at the San Andreas flight  school if you always wanted to pay to  enjoy the thrill an incineration of  being a patriotic hero without having to  put in real time and effort the san  andreas flight school is for you put  their life back into your midlife crisis  like any sensible new father learn the  art of hot-dogging in our new jets or  Swift helicopter or demonstrate your  continued manliness with a road rage  master air and land superiority and then  fly the flag of your country on our new  patriotic Athene's parachute bags it's a  fact women love men in uniform who  shower with other men and look moody  while riding motorcycles whoa look at  that come be part of the montage san  andreas flight schools the best of the  best